[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la première maternité au delà du fait
que en tant que femme à diego vers ce
jeu de nagui à un être dont z
j'étais loin d'imaginer que quelques
années plus tard mon petit poney sont
cela va être totalement impacté ma
carrière voire la bousculer
lorsque des circonstances de la
naissance de fénis était à spéciale j'ai
vécu à une opération qui a totalement
déséquilibrée bon système digestif et
enflammé mon estomac
quelques années plus de temps en temps
quelques semaines par an plus tard je
rentre au bénin et je fais cette
photo-là loin d'imad de m'imaginer que
dans les secondes qui suivront je vivrai
ma première crhiv à l'inflammation
maîtrise très violente à l'estomac au
compteur était crispé et j'avais très
mal à la gorge elles font suis une
suspension cession de crise une
succession une succession pour moi des
mois un jour sur deux gt toupatou temps
à l'hôpital
jusqu'à ce que je tombe sur un médecin
qui me dit madame hameau vous avez des
plaies à l'estomac et votre organisme
est totalement déséquilibré la mère me
dit il faudra que tu arrêtes de
consommer gibb et il doit séparer d'une
console de consoler par monts et faucons
d'avoir du maïs aussi ce qui était faux
nom et que tu es interne comme
alimentation le mieux le fonio et le
sorgho
bacon dans quelques mois j'avais ouvir
je pensais en tout cas on rentre au
bénin que voilà j'avais une sorte d'
équilibre nous méfier le matin le
chauffeur me dépose au bureau je suis
bien dans mon bureau je rentre le soir
quand ils mentent j'ai mon enfant que je
retrouvais ma petite famille j'essaie
d'équilibrer la et puis cette
inflammation créer un petit chaos dans
tout cela et je découvre les céréales le
mil le fonio le sango
qui a qui me permettent de
danser mais plaît à l'estomac de reiki
les bretons système digestif et qui
seront le déclic pour une nouvelle arche
dont ma mère a été en quelque sorte
l'initiatrice c'est marrant parce que
hier soir je me suis rendu compte qu'il
ya trois ans de cela j'étais à la grille
dans la salle à côté et je tiendrai une
conférence le leadership africain je
sais plus vraiment où je parle de ma
carrière professionnelle en tant que je
ne car dans une institution
internationale et je vais encore
aujourd'hui je vous raconterai une autre
espoir alors je me présente à moi je
m'appelle social vous je suis
entrepreneur féministe et je suis la
fondatrice de l'entreprise
boulot je ne serais pas là pour vous
parler de ma carrière professionnelle en
kick ass j'ai étudié l'histoire
puis les sciences politiques en gros
j'étais un double cursus
j'ai commencé en tant que responsable
dans une institution internationale
je suis rentré premièrement bénin en
2016 avant de repartir en 2017 et de
rentrer définitivement en 2018 donc en
2018 je rentre définitivement beynat
après avoir commencé à penser comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure quand j'ai
découvert les céréales anciennes à mûrir
ce petit projet peut-être entreprises à
faire des petits de recherche sur ce qui
est sûr ce qu'était part vend le mieux
le fonio le sorgho et a commencé à
constituer mon petit cerveau en fait
tous les éléments du monde en tout cas
du puzzle
et je rentre en 2018 je continue
toujours dans ma petite carrière
c'est bien c'est monique je reçus dans
un bureau climatisé tout ça je vais dans
des missions à bonjour je ne maîtrise
pas trop les villageois et je me
retrouvais toujours été peu fait avec
des collègues je peux le travail pour
lesquelles je suis là et bien je me
rends compte que c'est pas forcément la
sd dont j'avais que j'avais imaginé en
tout cas m'a dit que je voulais mener
quand j'étais encore là on n'y fait
moi j'aurais d'être au bénin quelques
années plus tard sur la terre de mes
ancêtres sans que ma merde le sache et
je n'imaginais créer quelque chose un
quart des hauts faits minute soit il
dans un petit pain pack moi ça me
dérange pas mais intacte et donc avec
mon ami dans le temps à à part on avait
créé une sorte de petite honte il est
tout ce qu on récoltait bas c'était pour
leur bail au bénin pour financer à le
champ d'un paysan est encore à manger
bon s'agrandit externe mais jamais avec
maman de créer quelque chose et
le 4 mars 2019 me voici là je me
réveille un matin je prends un sac à dos
avec métatexte je porte une robe et je
demande à un zen de m'amener au quelque
part je pourrais trouver un taxi pour
aller
au centre du bénin parce qu'apparemment
naba et peut-être au nord je trouverai
des coopératives de femmes pour qu'il
faut des céréales comme nuls fonio 200
go et le zénith m'amène quelque part à
touba et je discute avec le taximan je
n'ouvre qu'une photo parce que j'étais
loin de m'imaginer que ce serait le
début d'une aventure
ski évidence que il me dit le premier
arrêt ce sera à glace joué malgré cela
le village paternel de match fou et
c'est là que je rencontre ma première
coopérative ensuite elle mêlera a
beaucoup misé que j'apprendrai en tout
cas à découvrir plus tard bref j'étais
en train de chignons veut constituer
tout le monde faisait dans la tête est
ce qu'on devrait maintenant la question
de bon quand tu vas à quitter le boulot
comment tu vas faire comment tu à
subvenir à ses besoins apparaissent
d'accès curité financière coire et bon
j'essaie de parler d'haussmann amer mais
c'était c'était hors de question pour s
est pas possible non je n'étais pas
possible les charges il ya la petite
fille est là il ya pas même ton mode de
vie va baisser gibbons j'ai une sorte
des pins qui est là qui assez
conséquente forcément je reverrai un
mode de vie mais j'ai envie d'essayer
j'étais content je suis pas médecin
quand on sait quelque chose dans la tête
mais c'est donc seconde je peux alors
fermé je le ferai parce que pourquoi je
n'ai pas fait je me sens pas bien ou
encore dans le nam dans mon esprit et je
me dis au pire ce sera une leçon au
mieux j'aurai réussi à créer quelque
chose qui perdura dans le temps
et en une semaine
ça c'est fait j'ai quitté mon boulot on
nature ans quand même deux mais
l'arrière en tout cas ceux qui comptent
entreprendre au qui sont dans
l'entrepreneuriat vous le savez tous ce
dont je vous l'apprends la sécurité
financière c'est très important parce
que pendant un an ou deux vous serez
shell à investir dans votre propre
entreprise
en tout cas le ton roula le temps que la
rentabilité commence à porter ses fruits
content que la saison commence à porter
ses fruits par vous
et comme je me disais tu peux en une
semaine chez j'ai démissionné j'ai
assuré mes arrières et le 6 mai 2010
neuf agences pour mot aux
en alliance on va dire avec des
coopératives de femmes béninoises dont
la mission a été de est toujours
d'ailleurs un de leur assurer un revenu
fixe par mois mais surtout surtout
surtout de préserver nos terres
agricoles madame est des leurs et parler
d'un sujet très important c'est enfin
réseau aux balances et polluent les deux
pesticides du nord jusqu'au sud peintre
est le cas aussi de nos terres agricoles
pour compenser le maillet pourrait
pousser le riz pas il faut des pétitions
et je découvre qu'on fait pour faire ou
sur le fonio le mil et le sorgho il ne
faut pas cesser rien ou n'ont pas besoin
en fait vous les mettez dans le sol
elles se nourrissent des plus toute leur
énergie dans les minéraux de ses soldats
et lg amant elle faisait grève
nous allons les céréales très ancien
dont les vertus sont absolument
incroyable pour notre santé mais surtout
qu'ils apportent des réponses au
changement climatique
elle va avoir des réponses au changement
climatique
ce comme je vous dis je vous le disais
elle montre un besoin de pesticides on
ne tirait pas pardon pour cultiver
férial là elles puisent leur force dans
le sol et ex éclore bas bref me voici je
me réveille en tout cas ce film et 2019
à la tête d'une entreprise
donc j'étais très loin de m'imaginer ya
ne serait ce qu'au nom de cela parce que
vraiment l'année de l'entrepreneur je
vous le dis encore maintenant je ne
pense pas que ce soit un peu moins mais
on s'adapte à chaque fois parce que
c'est un petit déséquilibre il faut
chercher son équilibre outre-mer amie
sophie et serra et puis on essaie de
voilà deux jongles et on essaye je fais
de mon mieux chaque mois dans six mois
puis vous me direz magna daley la honda
et
voilà le lien entre ma fille vous le
bouleversement de la carrière
professionnelle qui pompait nombreux ma
mère mais elles seront coupés je ne je
m'épanouis d'année en année est
la raison pour laquelle je me bats
aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un nous
souhaiterons laisser à nos enfants sont
en tout cas moi ma fille d'abord mes
amis à mes nièces et aux années qui est
enfin en générations qui viendront ben
faudrait déjà qu'on revoit notre mode de
consommation
qu'est-ce que nous
alimentons pardon
consommer béninois
quand je dis consommer béninois s'est
d'abord consommer et serial du bénin
parce que par le fameux manga que tout
le monde connaît ba s'était battu avec
du maïs avant c'était fait avec plus
fournis auparavant net avec le cerveau
était avec lui ni le maillot orné son
entrée en afrique sous l'ère de
l'industrie quand le chrono minable
mois on travaille aujourd'hui c'est
d'amener les gens c'est de pousser les
gens à revoir leur mode de consommation
en consommant de manière consciencieuse
et surtout pardon en
soutenant le travail à deux ces
coopératives là
je suis enfin nos sols en décembre 2021
j'ai 27 ans je suis à cotonou et je
pense qu'on peut qu'être
l'alimentation des parties de notre
équilibre tant spirituelle que physique
et qu'elle définit plus ou mois les
personnes en tout cas ce serait fait ce
que l'on mange on vous fait elle nous
réflète tout simplement
alors je vais finir à montauk part par
une phrase que je sais pas si l'on peut
dire et ça mais que j'ai lu il ya
quelques mois par le feu haj et son
climat
sur tille simple que cela c'est mais
dévoile actions mais nous à l'action moi
je souhaiterais qu au moment où tout le
monde quittera ici mais en tout cas
toujours est-il après après vous avoir
parlé quand vous seriez confiant parce
qu'on ne parle quasiment pas au bénin
mais le changement climatique est réel
vous voyez on est en pleine période
harmattan mais on ne sent rien pendant
ce temps à part la poussière tout et
s'en vont devenir
l'ex maison depuis qui se raccourcissent
il fait de plus en plus chaud mais
surtout moi j'ai quelque chose geagea un
exemple réel qui me peine chaque jour
c'est la maison dans laquelle j'ai
grandi quand j'étais petit et qui est
envahie sous la mer aujourd'hui
tout ça ça fait partie du changement
climatique
5aujourd'hui pardon jeu en kit à un
mouvement dès maintenant je vous appelle
tous à
agir à être des acteurs et des actrices
de ce changement là et ça passe par des
petits gestes ça commence par consommer
en circuit court ça peut être auprès des
fermes parce qu'il ya des initiatives
aujourd'hui qui se créent ou vous
propose des paniers de fruits et légumes
chaque semaine ça peut être auprès des
âmes des vendeuses vous voyez des
petites bonnes dames dans les petits
marchés locaux ça c'est des circuits
comme ça qu'on stars éliminées de votre
alimentation
ballet des produits lehman et connaît ça
je comprends jamais pourquoi face fait
on marchait vous allez vous avez en
cours les vivants dont le consommer on
va vous le prenez votre chez vous et
vous savez ce que vous consommez vous
savez que dans votre assiette barnils
que j'ai consommé il vient de là la
guerre que j'ai consommé elle vient de
la lacc chose que j'ai consommé est bien
de la vous avez une idée de ce que vous
mangez bien juste en faisant ces petits
j'ai fait la barbe aux quotidiens bah
vous au participer à la préservation de
l'eau terres agricoles merci
[Applaudissements]